welcome back to cbs this morning
hospitals across america are struggling
to cope
with the surge of coronavirus cases in
new england
about 60 thousand new infections and 600
new deaths
were reported across six states in the
past week alone
mola lenghi is outside the rhode island
convention center in providence
which opened a large field hospital just
last week mulla good morning
good morning anthony inside this
convention center that you mentioned
there are about
600 beds currently treating about two
dozen patients that's in addition
to being one of the busiest testing
sites here in providence
now this field hospital is currently one
of at least three
up and running throughout new england we
got a firsthand look at another one
in nearby worcester massachusetts just
hours before it began accepting patients
when massachusetts closed its covid
field hospital in worcester
the hope was that they'd never need to
reopen this was one of the first field
hospitals in america
opened up on april 9th we closed down
around may 23rd
and now we're open again and there's no
other field hospital america that we're
aware of that has had to do that for
covid but as dr eric dixon
president of umass memorial healthcare
explained to us with covid cases
skyrocketing
overwhelming hospitals throughout the
state the 220 bed facility
had to be reconstructed and reopened was
it discouraging when you realized we're
gonna have to do this all over again
that the situation has gotten that bad
it didn't have to happen and we had the
virus
under control in massachusetts and as we
started to reopen the state
most people were doing the right thing
most of the time but that wasn't enough
it requires everyone to do the right
thing
every day if you're going to stop the
spread they have more beds and staff
than before
and enhanced capabilities like copper
pipes funneling in
oxygen for patients and it appears
they'll need it as the state's more than
247
000 confirmed cases jumped by more than
4 700
just yesterday neighboring rhode island
just opened this field hospital in
providence in the hopes of relieving its
strained hospital system
over the last week the state has led the
nation in
average daily cases per capita according
to the cdc
they shouldn't have to suffer this way
but holly soucy's parents
janet and richard gingras of providence
rhode island did suffer
especially richard a bout of hospital
delirium left him unaware of where he
was
or why he was there they died days apart
without each other or their beloved
family by their side
steven soucy was their grandson what
really hurt our family
and other families i'm sure is the
inability to go
and comfort them they were isolated
this was a couple that married for 69
years about to have their 70th wedding
anniversary
and all they could think about was each
other
well richard gingras will be buried on
thursday just one week
after his beloved wife of nearly 70
years was laid to rest
gail most public health officials say
they see no signs
of this virus slowing down but
with a vaccine on the horizon dr dixon
at the massachusetts field hospital
told us he is at least encouraged that
what we're going through right now
is not merely a second surge of covet
cases
but hopefully a final surge boy well i
hope that's right because we keep
hearing surge upon surge in the
thanksgiving cases have he
haven't even hit yet that's right that's
why it's so maddening to hear the
president say in particular that we're
we're rounding the corner rounding the
corner we're not
we're or to reach something claiming
that the hospitals are somehow fake when
we know they're reopening and being set
up anew
and we heard dr deborah burke say this
is the worst event in the country's
history not just from a public health
perspective
and as we've heard on this show over and
over again what doctors and nurses are
going through right now
it's i mean they are doing epic work and
they are at the breaking point based on
the trajectory we're on now for
fatalities dr burks is on
track the numbers are with her in terms
of total deaths it will be the worst
event in the country's history
and i know it feels like groundhog day
saying the same thing but we have to
keep saying the same thing over and over
hopefully people will get it a lot of
you have but a lot of you haven't